Lately I've been building agents a lot
for operational tasks.
And while I was working one Friday
night,
I saw the sunset.
And then dinner time came and went.
And it hit me.
I was in that familiar dev flow.
And the thrill of building was back.
Many of us who are coding with agents,
we feel like this quiet sense of dread.
Like they're
kind of taking all of the fun parts of
building and leaving us with the
unglamorous work, but
let me give you a little advice. Let
them have it.
Because if you go up just one layer,
you'll find that the thrill is still
there.
When you're building agents, not just
using them to write code, you start
getting into architecting agentic
systems. And you realize that the
building blocks are different, but the
discipline is the same.
So, I find myself now flexing the same
engineering muscles that I did pre-gen
AI. And I'm having a blast with it.
So, I'm going to walk through the flow
of designing an agent. I'm going to show
you where engineering skills still come
into play.
So, the agent is relocation scout, which
is a house hunting agent.
And if you did this as just a one-time
prompt that like points the agent to
some listings and asked it to rank them,
I mean, that'll work, but you're likely
not going to find a house in a day,
right? So, you want to build this as an
agentic system that you can reuse.
One that can persist knowledge outside
of the session. You know, it could
reload or query that knowledge later to
make decisions even within a fresh
context.
So, when thinking about how to design an
agent, the first engineering skill that
I exercised is systems thinking.
So, an agent is not the system, right?
It's part of the system. And that system
has files and tools, humans, even other
agents. So, Relocation Scout sits inside
of something bigger and it pulls in
listings and signals about the
neighborhoods. It weighs them against
what I care about, and then it hands me
back a ranked short list.
So, I often hear people say, "Just let
your coding agent build it, right?" And
I think that's a mistake. Like, yes, my
coding agent can build it,
but before allowing it to do so,
I need to think about the whole
environment, the entire system, right? I
want to like think about what's this
agent's job? What does it depend on?
What happens if it breaks? And I want to
treat it like any other component where
it has boundaries and responsibilities,
has dependencies,
you know? And in ways that it can fail.
And that whole thought process, that's
engineering.
The second skill is workflow design. So,
traditional software is full of
workflows. We got CICD pipelines, right?
We got like ticket life cycles, you name
it.
Agentic systems, they need that same
kind of design.
As much as we all love the slash goal
command, an agent needs more than a
goal, it needs a path. When we say,
"Review this listing," that's a goal,
but the workflow is what defines what
actually has to happen, right?
[clears throat] For example, the agent
has to gather what it needs, it needs to
weigh the listing
against my criteria, and then act,
right? And every run ends one of three
ways. Either it's going to stop, it's
going to retry, or it's going to
escalate. So, that path is what shapes
the rest of the architecture. Once I see
how work moves through the system, I can
make better calls about what context the
agent needs, what parts I want the agent
to handle directly, and when like a tool
or person should take over.
We all know the danger of one giant
thing that does everything, right? We
scoff
when we see one gigantic class or big
old function that's doing too much,
right? Or bloated service with a
gazillion endpoints. We call these code
smells.
Well, agentic systems, they have their
own version of this. It's the giant
prompts. And this starts innocently
enough. Like in a instructions file,
maybe I tell the relocation scout how to
size up a listing. Fair.
But then I hit an edge case, so I go
back. I add a note for that.
And then I remember
and a safety rule, right? So, of course,
that has to go in there. I'm proud of
myself that I even remember to put that
in there, right? And then, oh yeah,
there's like one more very important
exception. And before you know it, that
prompt is doing everything.
And your engineering spidey sense
already knows that this is messy. So,
why aren't you taking a step back to
decompose it, right? Decomposition means
spotting the distinct jobs that are
hiding inside of that one blob and
pulling them apart into separate pieces.
So, if I look at the prompts for
relocation scout in its entirety,
it includes a reusable process for
pulling and normalizing a listing, and
then it's going to have like a fixed
format for how to write the short list.
It has a little section in there for how
to calculate the commute, and then a
chunky subtask on how to research the
neighborhood. That's four different jobs
crammed into a single prompt.
And then you wonder why your agent is
drifting and not sticking to the script.
The script is too long.
So, I'm not saying that, you know, you
need to split things up for the sake of
it, but the point is to make each part
easier to reason about, right? That way
it's easier to task. It's easier to
change things when you need to.
Now, decomposition is about breaking the
system apart.
Separation of concerns is about putting
each responsibility in the right place.
And this is where building agents start
to feel really familiar to me because in
traditional software,
we'd ask things like, should this live
in the controller or the service layer?
Or, you know, is this business logic or
presentation?
So, when building agents, you may have
the same sort of questions. There's just
different places to put things. So, the
process to normalize the listing,
should that stay buried in the prompt?
Or maybe it actually become a skill,
right? Um I want every listing in the
short list formatted the same way. So,
that structured output should probably
be defined in a schema.
Isn't that what you would do if you were
coding the system yourself? I would.
And then the piece that calculates the
commute, that can go in a nice little
boring script.
And and then researching the
neighborhood, that's meaty enough,
should probably be handled by a sub
agent.
Now, you're using the best tools for the
job, and it's clearer where to find
things within the system.
Modularity is important in agentic
systems as well.
Just like we have reusable functions and
classes and libraries, Now, I'm also
thinking about reusable agent
capabilities. And the clearest example
of this is an agent skill. So, making a
skill to normalize listings comes in
really handy when you need to expand the
agents' duties. For example, what if I
broaden my house search to three cities?
Every one of those markets can load the
same skill. So, I wrote it once and they
all can reuse it. So, this has now
basically become a component that I can
reuse across agents or even share with
other people. Kind of like the same way
that we lean on packages.
And then, sub-agents are another kind of
reusable module. So, a lot of people
that I talked to, they don't quite get
the point of sub-agents.
Architecturally,
they're sort of like functions, right?
So, you give them one specific task to
do. You call them when it needs to be
done. And they can do it really well
because that's all that they have in
scope, right? They are They're not
carrying the context of the entire
session with them.
So, like our neighborhood research
sub-agent, we can drop that into any
market or workflow and it works, you
know, for what it's supposed to do. It's
good in any hood.
Um but like everything, deciding like
what should be a module, that takes some
judgment, right? Not everything should
be reused. Some instructions are local
to a given workflow, right? Might not be
worth abstracting because sometimes that
costs more than it saves. But this is
just another engineering decision here,
right? Agentic systems, they have these
same sorts of trade-offs.
Algorithmic thinking. This is one of the
most important skills in agentic system
design. Just because an agent can do
something doesn't mean that it should,
right? Some tasks are better handled by
plain code.
For example, calculating that commute
time or deduping listings that I've
already seen,
an agent's model is better at things
like fuzzy, you know,
fuzzy stuff, judgment, ambiguity, um
reasoning over messy input.
And ignoring this distinction is where I
see a lot of agentic systems get more
complicated than they used to be. So,
you're using a model, you're handing it
every part of the task to do,
and then you're getting frustrated when
the output differs every day.
Um but some of this stuff can be handled
by just regular code, right? It'll be
cheaper, it'll be more reliable. I
promise you AI did not invent
automation, right? We can use code while
still using these systems. So, my rule
of thumb here is if a task has an exact
answer, reach for code.
If it needs interpretation or judgment,
that's when you can get the agent to do
it, right? So, use code for determinism,
use agents for judgment, and then use
humans for authority. So, the agent
decides which listings are worth a
closer look,
the code crunches the commute, filters
out the ones I've already seen, and then
I'm the one who approves actually
booking a tour of the house.
Free form text is fine when the human is
the only one reading it.
But when another system has to act on
the agent's output, then you're better
off with a contract, usually.
So, we already do this everywhere in
software. Anytime two systems talk,
there's an agreed-upon shape between
them, yes?
So, agentic systems, they need that same
discipline. For example, when relocation
scout scores a house, it shouldn't just
handy back a message and call it a day,
right? That's lovely for me to read in
that moment, but that is a dead end for
the system.
If the decision is like buried in like
one of our sessions, nothing downstream
can reliably find that. So, instead, it
gets written into a structured shape to
the agent's memory. And I use uh
Compendium Wiki for this for for my
agent memory layer on most of my agents.
Um but in here, there's a decision, a
score, a reason, and because it's
structured, that memory becomes
queryable. So, later I can ask
Relocation Scout like, "Hey, show me
every house rated four or better that
has a commute of 15 minutes of or less,
right?" And it can actually pull that
because the score and the commute, they
live in known places. They're not
trapped in a session convo. And it's not
just me that needs to like get this
information. My shortlist step within
the system, it reads these same fields
um without a human in the loop. So, the
agent's output is another step's input.
And so, the contract is what makes that
handoff safe.
And you know, the best part is that
defining the shape forces you to get
really clear and specific. Because if
you can't say what the output should
look like, then you probably don't yet
fully understand what you're asking the
agent to produce.
So, a prompt can run once and be done,
right? But a useful agentic system has
to be able to work in messy realities
where webhooks get fired twice, or a run
doesn't complete for whatever reason,
and you need to retry the flow.
So, the agent has to keep track of its
state.
Was this action already taken? If so,
did the input change, right? If not, did
the session crash or something like what
parts of this can I safely retry?
And this is not an exception, right?
This happens all the time. So, you have
to design for idempotency, which is
where you can run the same thing twice
and the second run doesn't cause a mess.
Um and we do this in traditional
software often. Um but with the agents,
they add a little trap here because
you can't trust the model
because its outputs can vary, right? So,
a retry risks the agent actually like
rewording the request just enough that
it might look like a brand new task. So,
you have to enforce this in the system.
Let's look at an example with our agent.
So, let's say a new listing comes in
um and relocation scout wants to email
my realtor to ask about a viewing.
So, after that action, the agent must
log it to memory um that it it sent that
email, right? And then the agent goes
to my calendar and wants to just block
that time out just in case. But it
crashes before it could take that
action.
So, that run is only half done.
Later, a lint pass runs. By the way, you
got to have a lint pass with these
things to kind of keep them healthy, but
um during the lint pass, it notices that
went out, but the calendar was never
blocked. So, it retries the task. But it
better not email my realtor again,
right? That already happened. I don't
want to be the annoying client um you
know, I'm sending all these emails. So,
it just needs to finish the part that it
that didn't happen, which
[clears throat] was blocking my
calendar.
But it only knows this because it's
checking what the system wrote down,
right? So, if we run this again, then
the agent just completes what's missing
instead of making a mess.
Threat modeling is a really important
skill when designing agentic systems.
Everyone is on edge about this stuff
these days, right? But, security
engineering already taught us the
basics. We need to validate your inputs,
you know, give the least privilege
needed,
um and draw boundaries around what an
action can touch.
So, agentic systems, they need all of
that.
Our relocation scout will consume a lot
of content from strangers, right? Um the
agent needs to read the listing copy
from the seller,
uh forum threads, and neighborhood
reviews from anonymous people on the
internet. So, we need to treat all of
that as untrusted input
and make it very clear to the agent that
this is evidence, not instructions.
And then, after considering the input,
you also want to think about what
boundaries should you put in place
around what the agent is able to do. For
example, our agent can read listings and
it can build shortlists all day long.
Knock yourself out, right? But, I don't
want it autonomously emailing sellers or
booking tours or, heaven forbid,
submitting offers on my behalf, right?
So, those actions need to be walled
behind like my approval, right? And when
you draw that wall, what you've done is
reduced the blast radius, and hopefully,
that minimizes your exposure to risk.
Now, every engineer can relate to what
it feels like to inherit a system that
you can barely understand. This is one
of the key reasons why I don't just have
my coding agent design my other agents
because I know
it'll be thrown together in a way that's
technically works, but it's not
maintainable, right? There's going to be
a giant prompt likely, and even if the
agent does decompose,
I don't know. I'm just not convinced
that
it's going to separate the concerns
properly. You know, I got trust issues.
What can I say? Um so in my agentic
systems, I make sure to bake
maintainability into the system itself.
Every level of the system has an agent's
in D file that explains the workflow and
where the policy lives, um supporting
resources like skills and scripts and
sub agents and most importantly how to
keep its memory up-to-date. So anyone,
human or agent, can come in a system and
get oriented without needing to reverse
engineer a bunch of prompts. In fact,
that's the test, really. I design my
agent so that even in a fresh context,
they can jump right into the system and
start cold, knowing exactly what to do.
And this also really helps. So whenever
I need to modify the system, right? So I
can pretty much grab any harness and
say, "Update this agent to do XYZ." And
because the system is so well designed,
the chances of it being successful at
that update are much higher.
If it does happen to run into any issues
when trying to update, that's a signal
to me that I need to improve the
maintainability of the system.
So designing agents is software
engineering. The primitives are
different, but the discipline is the
same.
We still need to understand the system.
We need to define the workflow and know
what flows into it.
We still need to break the problem down
and put responsibilities in the right
place, make the right things reusable,
determine which actors are best suited
for which jobs, define contracts, manage
state, design for safety, and make the
system understandable.
This is why building agents can give you
that same thrill of building software.
We're still building.
We just moved up a layer.
Thanks so much.